me
9-4
やはりじゃなくて今日は弾いポッターの魔法の基礎の基礎を押すよと思う
お前ら魔法で大事な何か遊び同士だったはい今回はこちらの
魔法でもなってね7なんでこんなことしてんだろうそうではなんでもないんですけど
こちらですポケットボードというね
こちらのボードなるんですけどもう製剤ボードが2つ入って言ってこういう小さい
ボードに足を置くだけでもこういう感じで乗れるといういわゆるスケボーの調子祭
バージョンで何か使いやすいバージョンみたいなかあるんで
じゃあ僕たち
な新米のはマを使ってちょっと移動手段も放棄とだよまだチョイ乗りなくて困ってるん
だよ
これを練習してこれでどうしようと思いますチャッチャッパ
あっはぁん
これ汗肯定されない歌うされない
無理じゃれながら一路聞かせろ進行方向にポケットボード鍋できますまず
右側の足を乗せません4次に左足合うコートに載せまこの時つま先10発ような
イメージで j
まず片側のボードを水平に立てますで次に
残り片側の方どうせ前に建てた後左右のボードをスライドたてるけど全然します
ok ok ok ok ようですいきますはい
版べらべも生きるんだそういうことが多いできるぞいますか次への良かったってこう
でしょそう
いや僕ちぃーっすけ
4ああそうかもはやおかしいでしょこれカッコ悪いことだけでしょ
ああそうか最近多いと思うぞいるキッズ凸ぢにそう言ってよい
ok もう行けますもうね2巻猫っ風呂
th
平明ずみなよ鱈婆が赤間がん
then
難しいよねぇああ
あーやっぱ知ったスイカをするねー
風に泡やすいかもしれないですね
wh
me
ん